[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in less than an hour joe
biden begins his annual state of the
union address imagine if he dared to be
honest about it what would he say what
is the state of our union tonight well
in a word it is fragile very fragile the
united states is poorer it's more
fearful it's far less free than it was
when joe biden became the president just
13 months ago joe biden inherited a
divided country a very divided country
and then he proceeded to make it much
angrier history will judge joe biden for
that but in the meantime voters already
are biden's poll numbers have dropped to
the point that it's impossible to
explain them without admitting that
you're at fault it's not just unvaxed
confederate q and seditionists who
disapprove of joe biden at this point
much as the white house suggests
otherwise it's pretty much everyone who
lives here apart from the bitter 50
something year old wives or private
equity barons they're skiing in aspen
right now and they still love biden
but everyone else has second thoughts
and that would include many americans
who once supported joe biden it would
include hispanic voters independent
voters an awful lot of black men
at this point disliking joe biden
disapproving as his pr of his
performance may be the single thing that
unites this country it is a rainbow
coalition of disdain
so that's what biden is up against
tonight question is how does he explain
his failures and the answer is mostly he
doesn't
biden is guaranteed to make sympathetic
noises about inflation and gas prices he
has no choice but to do that but he also
has no answers he cannot fix the
problems that he has caused
thankfully from his perspective and
we're preparing you this is very cynical
biden now has a war to talk about and of
course that's what he will do tonight
the white house understands the invasion
of ukraine is a chance to change the
subject it is what bloomberg news
described today as a political reset
so forget what biden did to your country
and your economy and your children's
school joe biden is winston churchill
now and by the way vladimir putin is the
one who's brain damaged the cia can
prove it
we're about to hear a lot of that how
much of it can you believe well some of
it some of it is true
vladimir putin really did invade ukraine
that really is bad they're not just
saying it putin's invasion destabilizes
europe thanks to the recklessness of our
leaders we could wind up at war with
russia and that would be a legitimate
disaster no matter what the outcome
might be so that's we know for certain
but beyond that in the realm of any
other detail our advice is be very wary
of what you hear
there is an awful lot of lying going on
an unprecedented amount of lying
this war is a humanitarian tragedy
that we know
but the war is also a political event
that various groups including in this
country are leveraging feverishly in the
hope of gaining more power for
themselves that is real
so to gain that power they're
manipulating you the consumer of news
and they're doing it in ways that are
often hidden and therefore highly
insidious and we would say immoral
much of the information about the war
that you're ingesting uncritically has
in fact been curated by the tech
monopolies and yes by the intel agencies
by the time it reaches your iphone some
of that information to restate is
entirely real some of it is fake
so the question is how do you know the
difference how do you know when you're
being manipulated as you certainly are
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else